hey 42 here space is unbelievably
strange you will be forgiven for
thinking that's every planet out there
is similar just a big ball of rock and
gas what planets are remarkably more
unique than that here's a top strangest
planet in the known universe that seemed
like they belong in some bizarre science
fiction series first up is this dark
menacing planet affectionately named
tress to be it is located 750 light
years away from our solar system as far
as we know it is officially the darkest
planet in the entire universe it
reflects less than 1% of all lights that
hits it making it significantly darker
than the majority of known exoplanets
his ominously dark surface can partially
be explained by the light absorbent
gases that make up the bulk of the
planet but scientists don't really know
for sure why it is so dark but it gets
creepier not only does his evil-looking
ball of gas not reflect any light it
actually glows a molten red color as if
it's a hot ball of coal on fire this is
because the surface of the planet is a
punishing 1,100 degrees Celsius which is
so hot that it glows red this next
planet is anything but dark
in fact it sparkles luminescent Li in
space just like a diamond because well
it is in fact a gigantic diamond yes
that's right this planet named 55 Cancri
E is about twice the size of Earth and
the third of it is made up of solid
diamond the planet is very carbon heavy
and the planet is so dense that all
carbon is in the form of solid diamond
but don't get too excited the diamond
planet is located a spectacular 40
light-years away from Earth and even if
you could travel that far and retrieve
the endless supply of diamonds it has to
offer
there is so much diamond on the planet
that bringing even a minut fraction of
it back to earth would completely
overwhelm the diamond supply and
therefore make diamonds completely
worthless so this beautiful planet is
best admired from afar this next planet
seems to defy everything you thought you
knew about chemistry because it's a
giant ball of ice on fire imagine for a
second you're on the ice planet hoth
from Star Wars well that's exactly what
Gliese 436 B would look like except that
the icy surface is constantly burning at
439 degrees Celsius so how can this big
how can i stuff I the laws of chemistry
and stay completely solid at 439 degrees
above its melting point
well the planet's gravity is so
immensely strong that it pulls the
melted ice water towards its core
compressing it into a solid form
stopping it from ever evaporating no
matter how much it burns next time you
complain about the weather on earth just
stop for a moment and be thankful that
you don't live on the planet HD one
eight nine seven seven three big where
it constantly rains glass sideways this
planet's atmosphere is full of silicon
particles which give it its beautiful
blue color but because of the planets
extremely high surface temperatures
these silicon particles condense to form
solid glass which flies around the
planet sideways in its endless four
thousand miles per hour winds but hey at
least it's not as bad as living on what
12b
this poor of unfortunate client is
slowly being eaten alive by its star
it's caught up in an orbit so close to
its star that the whole planet has been
heated up to unimaginably high
temperatures and its mass is slowly
being sucked up as it hurtles around the
star extremely fast the planet is
roughly the size of Jupiter however it
appears to be larger because the molten
temperatures of its parent star have
caused wasp 12b to balloon or this poor
planet loses an incredible 6 billion
metric tons of mass per second
in fact it's being torn apart so quickly
that it's no longer a sphere but an egg
like oblong shape next up is Gliese 581c
this planet is very special because it's
being voted by the scientific community
as one of the top three exoplanets
likely to support alien life however
it's very different to earth it orbits a
red dwarf star so if you looked up into
the sky it would always be a deep
crimson red color the planet is also
tied a lot which means it doesn't rotate
on its axis just like our moon's
relationship to earth one side of the
planets is always facing away from its
star and the other always facing towards
it the side of Gliese 581 say that is
always facing this red dwarf star is so
blisteringly hot that if you were to
stand there it would melt you alive
however the opposite side of the planet
facing away from this star is so cold
that you would instantly freeze so you
may be wondering how could this
extremely violent planet possibly
support life similar to humans well
there is a narrow strip of one's halfway
between its hot side and it's icy side
that is just the perfect temperature to
support life but be careful not to take
step on the wrong side or you will most
certainly be toast
in 2008 we sent a message from Earth
directly at Gliese 581c and it's
expected to reach the planet in 2029
next up is a planet in the Scorpius
constellation known as wasp 17b what
makes this giant of a planet so peculiar
is it sheer size it is 1.9 times the
size of Jupiter which is the largest
planet in our solar system it's so large
that theoretically it should not exist
according to scientists it breaks the
laws of how larger planets can actually
get for its size it also has an
extremely low density because of this it
fits into a very unique class of planets
called puffy planets yes that's actually
a scientific term puffy planets are
planets with an extremely large radius
and a very low density for their size
but that's not all that makes wasp 17b
so strange it also has a retrograde
orbit which means that it rotates in an
opposite direction to its host star you
may remember that Luke Skywalker's home
planet of Tatooine in Star Wars had two
sons but as is often the case real life
can be much more amazing than science
fiction 149 light-years from Earth is a
planet to have not one not two but three
stars this free star planet which goes
by his catalog name of HD one eight
eight seven five three a bee sits within
the triple star system HD one eight
eight seven five three if you could live
on this planet you would experience
triple shadows and constant eclipses as
its three parent stars crossed each
other's paths and of course you would
see some of the strangest and most
beautiful sunsets and
Sun rises in the universe now imagine
you're in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean the sky is blue with fluffy white
clouds but there's no lunge to be seen
in every direction you turn is just
endless water well that's exactly what
it would be like if you were to visit
this planet forty-seven light-years away
from Earth which goes by its catalog
name of gj1214b that's because it's made
up entirely of water many scientists
have nicknamed this planet the water
world the entire surface of the planet
is one giant continuous ocean and it
remains exactly the same for miles
underneath the surface until eventually
you hit the planet's core which is
coated in a thick layer of solid ice but
this isn't any ordinary ice it's not the
kind of ice you would find in your
freezer because this ice isn't frozen
due to cold temperatures the water in
the planets core is under such immense
levels of pressure from the surface that
the water above the core has been
compressed into solid ice this is a very
special form of ice known to scientists
as i.7 'unless but not least 470
light-years away is a planet discovered
by the Kepler space observatory known as
Kepler for free 8bit this planet is very
strange not because it has any extreme
features but quite the opposite because
it is to date the most earth-like
planets we have ever found the Earth's
similarity index is a standard measure
of how similar to earth another planet
is with a score of 1 being identical to
earth in every way and zero being
nothing like Earth Kepler for free eight
being both unimpressive Earth similarity
index of 0.88 making Kepler for free
eight be super rare
unvarying discovered in January 2015
this planet has all the right
prerequisites for alien life most
importantly it is a rocky world just
like Earth and the proximity to its host
star puts it in what scientists called
the Goldilocks Oh which is the holy
grail of space exploration the
Goldilocks zone is when a planet is not
too close to its parent star that it's
too hot for life yet not too far away
that it's too cold water is essential to
life where there's water there's
probably life but in order to have
complex life there has to be liquid
water which most of the time can only
occur in the Goldilocks zone so Kepler
48b a rocky planet in the Goldilocks
zone is highly likely to have liquid
water runs there for life which makes it
one of the strangest and most
interesting exoplanets we have ever
discovered thanks for the view subscribe
for more thoughty2
[Music]